it's a thousand dicks [ __ ] disgusting
good I've been involved in crimes Leia
why don't you know that who the hell is
gonna wipe that up hey guys and welcome
back to the Leia heilpan show so today
we are going to be reacting to one of my
most viral videos which is of me
interviewing people in London about
Andrew Tate now joining me to laugh at
these people is the one and only Gideon
my amazing brother oh wow what an intro
oh give me some Mike wow what an intro
hey Lele gang
oh is this not the Leo gang no well I'm
giddy gang and this is Lele don't do
that so we're going to be talking we're
gonna be okay right
right
um before we do this reaction video
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe before we watch
this I want to let you know that we
purposely refuse to watch this video for
the last two weeks so that when we
reacted to it it would be genuine so
let's do this so do you guys know who
Andrew Tate is oh my God no ick no
absolutely not absolutely not well I
definitely like Andrew Tate isn't it
obvious I don't know I'm asking people
today quite a horrendous person we love
feminism and not him the minute she said
we love feminism like we already know
where these people are going he
advocates in
people to be against women's rights
basically does he yeah
at that point that girl also said does
he like her friend knew straight away
that her other friend was speaking BS
well do you want examples I'll get my
Google out I'd love examples let's see
let's see if we get some examples of how
wait what the hell why did she say like
I'll get my Google out what is like who
even talks like that I'll get my Google
out is advocating a group of men to sort
of take away the rights of women well
the guardian says that the guardian is
like the most biased left-wing piece of
propaganda that there is that Andrew
Tate says women belong in the home can't
drive in our man's property I'm no one's
property and anyone who thinks I can go
[ __ ] themselves I think he sort of means
they take care of a woman the same way
he'd take care of his other property
like his house his car it means he's
going to look after her isn't that quite
nice I mean being someone's property is
not nice because I don't belong to
anyone I can take care of myself thank
you very much here's the thing you're
never gonna have to worry about that
issue you never are going to be any
man's property I mean just look at you
who the hell is going to wife that up
do you like him he has a lot of
influence and it's dangerous he prefers
women who have slept with less men do
you agree what do you think
I think the
it's very
strange
View
but actually can we go again I just want
to let you know there's words out I
stood there for at least 15 minutes
speaking to this guy I kid you not he
said nothing it was unbelievable but the
funny thing is about that guy he
literally wants to be a politician he
thought that that was his moment you
know with his stupid voice like oh yeah
basically Andrew paid like what the [ __ ]
is that kind of I just try and I he's
the one that I've avoided what about his
daily life you obviously don't like him
so what about him specifically is the
issue this is how we start the interview
they've made an opinion we don't like
him cool now you need to substantiate
that back that up I think people
um like him are
um violent and aggressive towards like
minorities and I'm just not you think
Andrew's violent towards minorities and
women no I don't think you just said
that he just said that Andrew is violent
to minorities and then he goes no no the
minute you put him on the spot here is I
think he
it's what
it's what like
in the comments I mean there's in the
comments yeah let's just go straight in
the comments if it's the comment section
that you don't like that's not really
Andrew's fault is it
um I think it has a certain anybody
that's kicking off what is you have a
responsibility
um as a public figure
um to
this girl next to me that's his friend
and we're both there waiting for him to
like perform as a man like we're both
there waiting for him to like say
something basically waiting for this guy
to come up with an actual excuse as to
why he doesn't like Andrew tape all he
could do is um um um in the comments
what kind of behavior do you feel like
he's encouraging
um you're Crossing her arms waiting for
him to perform like
I hate speech primarily it's like it's
like his brain just defaults well I
always ask people why they don't like
Andrew Tate they never can give me
congruent factual based stuff he hasn't
got a criminal record like what's it
what's he done that people don't like
well I think it's um to be honest with
you the oh my God here we go again but
he goes like I think it's to be honest
with you like as if he's about to say
something of substance we haven't only
just been standing there for like 15
minutes trying to have a serious
conversation here
I think it's this the kind of this
situation
[Music]
situation with um do you guys know who
Andrew Tate is oh these are my favorite
girls I love yeah who he is yeah do we
like him do we not like him
why not said misogynist I need to find
misogyny men and friends and women and
then that's a typical thing people
always say that I love how we put them
on the spot like that Define misogyny
men are better than women it literally
doesn't even mean that it just means the
pure hatred towards me it's not a
superior thing but none of them can even
answer this because none of them know
what they're saying they're just
regurgitating everything they hear from
their girlfriends Tick Tock the media
you know but also you know they're just
regurgitating it because they speak and
sound the same way look how they both
answered the thing yeah do you know who
Andrew Tate is yeah yeah like what I've
actually heard him once say that women
are the most precious thing in the world
what do you think about that but that's
like in like olden times a woman had to
like stay at home I think it's the worst
example for boys like our generation
what don't you like about him why would
it be bad for boys to be like Andrew
Tate
just like how he views women how does he
use women
um
oh my God I really don't know oh another
one can he get me so embarrassing
something that he's done which is bad to
women give us an example
no like nothing comes to my head
actually I'm telling you I don't know
what to say so maybe he's not that bad
when you're out with a man would you
like him to sort of read and maybe pay
for you no like 50 50. you don't want a
man to look after you and provide for
you no I want my own job so since we're
all equal and say you're on a date with
a guy and another man comes when I
interview or go up to other girls or
even guys you know they think I'm on
their side like they don't think it's a
trap but it's really not a trap there's
no leading questions here and when I
start playing Devil's Advocate there's a
look in their eyes the way they look at
me like it just changes and they give me
like this look of hatred it's actually
so uncomfortable yeah basically in a
nutshell they know they got punked when
I approached them on the street and I
asked them oh hey would you like to do a
quick interview asking about a celebrity
oh yeah sure be famous and then they
realize we go with the hard-hitting
questions and they're like [ __ ] we just
got punked it's so uncomfortable but I
also tell that Leia will play Devil's
Advocate if you say you love him lay
will say she hates him but yeah they
give Leia the death stare after they
realize that Leia actually likes this
guy it's so uncomfortable Hamza tries to
like slap your bug what would you expect
your man to do he should like stick up
for it why now he's putting himself in
the firing line
yeah but what you go why don't you put
yourself in the firing line
but only equal when it comes to buying
dinner
boom exactly so crazy gotcha we're all
equal until it comes to a man risking
his life when a building's burning on
fire should we send the women in no we
let's send the men in when there's a
wash we send the women no we'll send
them in but I thought we were all equal
he's attractive child so whatever that's
atrocious that's disgusting like Andrew
tastes attracted to Children Well 18 to
19 year olds and how old is he he's 36
but that's not a child what's really
funny here is when she says this
allegation of the Andrew Tate is
attracted to Children one that's so bad
you've just gone there like everybody
can universally accept that that [ __ ]
except well except for the wokies these
days and even her friend is looking like
oh don't go there you just said Andrew
Tate's attracted to Children you got
caught on camera saying that she's just
digging herself deeper and then she goes
well 18 to 20 year olds it's like that's
not children and like these people don't
understand the weight of their work yeah
when you make accusations like that 30
careful with words it's not a child it's
not a child it's not a child but it's
very uh I think if it's legal east of
their own as long as it's consensual
don't you think
you also spoke about not needing a man
but do you ever feel like sometimes you
know the world is kind of dangerous out
there like you don't want someone to
like protect you if somebody tries to
like hit on you or if a man comes and
grabs you or whatever it is I'm from New
York I'll kick your ass if I give a [ __ ]
what if he's got a gun New York
gangsters New York gangster feminist
guys and she's like and you think I
haven't dealt with that I don't know
I've just met you like she's so angry at
me if you haven't I'm like I don't know
yeah because she's a New York feminist
gangster lady yeah I've been involved in
crimes Leia why don't you know that I
don't know part of human trafficking or
something like that what people keep
saying that he does human trafficking
but he hasn't been charged with anything
at all because he left the country you
know so the allegation was in Romania
but there's no evidence at all some
people keep saying these things but it's
um he hasn't been charged with anything
yeah but like even what he says in his
video I've watched a little on Tick Tock
as a feminist I don't appreciate how he
talks about women when you have as a
feminist like that's it the
conversation's over if you use that
label as an argument then I just know
we're not saying eye to eye because it's
just like I don't care what you're
saying as a feminist and again that was
super uncomfortable she seemed like a
super sweet girl but perpetuating lies
about human trafficking a woman that
slept with thousand men would you really
marry her the fact they've stayed with a
thousand men won't change anything bro
has no standards whatsoever you need to
do some research what does it mean if a
woman is sleeping around like that
that's a thousand dicks [ __ ] this
[ __ ] disgusting ten is too many
someone helped that man I like his
forwardness and I like that he's trying
to get people out of the Matrix and I
like the fact that he's trying to show
or remind men about masculinity because
really dying out in today's world how do
you know that he treats women badly he
talks about it in his video can you give
me an example because I haven't seen him
say anything bad or mean towards women
really because I've met him personally
and I've never experienced anything
negative and all you guys are have seen
is through Tick Tock exactly yeah okay
but if you met him for a few minutes bro
what are you talking about man no I know
we're friends he's a friend he's a good
friend I've met him plenty of time do
you not think there's a problem with
judging people from what you see on the
internet things have been taken out of
context I saw just just a lot of content
she knows she knows what you're saying
is wrong like what can you give me an
example just pour on the spot so much it
was a few months ago
sometimes they think like they're having
a conversation with me because I would
like fire points at Leia just like fire
at them and then they're looking at me
trying to answer me I'm like no no that
way look at the camera don't look at me
they hated me just as much as they hated
you you can even see like she's so on
the defense like she jumps back like I
don't know we make legitimate points
you're just judging someone you see on
the [ __ ] internet we've met him in
real life we know how he is so wouldn't
we have a better judge of character one
of the things that everyone has an issue
with is that he said women are the
property of men what's your take if it
comes to relationships I do believe that
the met the man prays a different role
compared to the woman yeah that's what
Andrew's saying I actually agree I think
women are the property of their husbands
not random people like this is where
everybody gets so confused by women
aren't the property of random men I'm
not the property of my brother it has
nothing to do with enslavement people
think it means enslavement and people
also get confused because they're like
if you're the property of someone so
your husband it means like you can't
leave and you're stuck no if the guy is
abusing you go go to the policeman go
evolve the problem is all people need to
do is use a bit of common sense a little
bit of that but that's all you have to
use your brain but people don't want to
think anymore days well that's the
problem is thinking is painful for the
brain yes it requires you to actually do
something some work you know instead of
collecting your government welfare
you're sitting on your ass watching
Netflix sitting on your fat lazy
American ass it's what getting
brainwashed with a propaganda Doritos
and your Pepsi in your mum's basement
with your mask and your and your mouth
like And subscribe I think we made the
point they get it what would your
message be to Andrew take is he gonna
see this yeah really okay cool so I'm
really I say that you should continue
doing what you're doing because you're
putting out a message that most people
in today's world try to ignore I really
appreciate you mate I keep doing what
you're doing don't give up I just want
to talk about London just like a split a
second we're both from London I haven't
been home in like five months there was
no normality it's so weird I'll tell you
what everybody on the street remember we
did go to the most work partner not even
because we went to other parts first
remember and actually we went up to
other people well that's what I'm saying
so there was no normality we went up to
people and everybody seemed afraid
everybody seemed ill everybody seemed
miserable and like depressed I'm based
out in Miami and in Miami everybody is
like upbeat loving life like you know
just trying to do better back there
everyone's walking around like a victim
I think at the end of the day people
just need to use a bit of common sense
with everything he's saying from Men are
the property of women like obviously it
means when you're in a serious
relationship the man has a degree and
responsibility of authority over the
woman it's like that simple that is so
normal but everybody wants to blow it
out the water like it's something else
yeah speaking of authority over women I
just want to say my brother is really
smart and so like I tend to listen to
everything he says it's not about
controlling or authority it's just it's
about understanding that if you have a
man in your life that is really
intelligent and you think he is and you
respect him then sure let him tell you
what to do God honestly I was so glad
once this video was done it was really
one of the most uncomfortable
experiences I know it's hilarious but it
was honestly so uncomfortable it's even
given me a headache watching it back
yeah like the fat pink guy and then the
fat girl like they're so illogical and
irrational and the inability to think
independently and thought and action
NPCs I can't deal with them anyway guys
let us know what kind of videos you want
us to do next and please don't forget to
hit the like button and subscribe
because there's so much more of this
coming we'll see you soon